over the long run climate change
is going to hurt millions if not
billions if we cannot cope with it in a
serious way
it's an existential threat the way we
live is at the
essence of how we deal with that issue
and the way we live is the product of
the environment we build
when we build a city we build a set of
behaviors
we build our own lifestyle our
relationships
to nature our relationships to each
other our relationships to money
you know they're all prescribed in ways
that we even stop
seeing we just take for granted that
this is the normal way
of being and so much is predetermined by
the way we shape our cities that i think
it's the most potent
tool we have to confront a lot of
our long challenges not our short
challenges
now a lot of projections show that
we're going to get to 70 percent of the
global population in cities
cities are where 80 percent of the
economic activity is
it's where 70 percent of the energy gets
used
we're going to add another 3 billion
people to cities
largely in the emerging economies in the
global south
but we're also going to remake our
cities as well in the next
30 40 years and we've got to get it
right
but this is what cities do it's where
innovation happens it's where people
go for economic opportunity it's where
women get a chance to have standing in
their society
it's where education and literacy takes
off
it's where economic growth happens for
developing
societies and it is proven many times
over
that it's the low carbon way to live and
it's the lightest footprint on the earth
meanwhile we look at what's around us
and it's becoming more and more painful
homelessness racism the early impacts of
climate change whether it's fire or
flooding
these are things that are upon us now we
have to think systemically about them
cities are our biggest opportunity to
stop
being wasteful of land of energy of
materials
of human potential